you
[Music]
self-driving cars delivery drones and
Internet service delivered through
floating balloons those are just some of
the projects that have come out of
Google's ex lab the secret of Silicon
Valley lab tasked with imagining and
developing futuristic technologies but
what else are the companies exceptional
minds envisioning Atlantic magazine
senior editor Derek Thompson had the
chance to go inside his article Google X
and the science of radical creativity
appears in this month's issue Derek it's
great to see you again my friends very
good to see you as well okay so how did
you get into this secret lab in the
first place
basically we worked it out with the
magazine to get me exclusive access to
some of their new projects and it was
really fun you know I felt like you know
Charlie Bucket and during the Chocolate
Factory you go into the lobby and
there's a part self-driving car and
there are drones hanging from the
rafters it looks like a Museum of
alternative futures and it was really
exciting to be able to talk to these
people about these projects that could
be months years even a decade away from
becoming real companies self-driving
cars drones contact lenses that measure
your tears for glucose and see if you
need the insulin injection just some
really interesting and fun snot exactly
is the purpose of X it has a dual
purpose and the dual purpose is one to
develop companies that have a 10x return
somehow that improve the world by a
factor of X 10 and companies that can
build essentially the next Google so
change the world and build and build the
next Google and it's interesting because
sometimes these two purposes are aligned
but as I talk to the the people there I
push back a little bit and I said you
know you look at companies like Facebook
designed initially just to digitize a
college yearbook and ended up becoming
the sort of the global infrastructure of
information so sometimes big projects
invent the future other times
incremental innovation does but they
it's not all just wacky out there ideas
right I mean this is it sounds like
there's a fairly rigorous assessment
process in terms of developing this
technology yes there actually is so
there is a group at X called the rapid
evaluation team I say they're like a
Justice League of nerds you have
metal scientists and psychologists and
philosophers and you enter a room and
you pitch a new idea so I did at the
beginning this article I go into the
room and I say I have an idea we need
more housing density in rich productive
cities let's build houses on the ocean
how do we think about that and it was
fascinating to watch these people sort
of you know mull over the idea and tease
it out and question my premises what
exactly are you trying to accomplish why
are we trying to build more housing in
dense cities it's really wonderful and
interesting to sort of watch their minds
at work this whole idea of idea labs I
mean it's it's been around in the past
you had to mean Xerox at one time had a
Palo Alto Research Center AT&T of course
had Bell Labs are we going back to that
you think I hope we I hope we do I think
that you know I looked at access sort of
like a microcosm of the US economy that
we need in every economy both inventions
science and innovation which is the
ability to take scientific discoveries
and commercialize them and the u.s. used
to be fantastic at this you know in the
1940s 1970s we came up with the
transistor at Bell Labs we came up with
the guts of the modern computer at Xerox
PARC
and now we're lacking some of that
ambition I think in the corporate sector
and in the government and it would be
nice to have that spirit of invention
come back to us government funding for
invention has gone down in the last
couple 70% since the 1950s dramatic
drop-off now not everything is a winner
an X right Google glass is a notorious
failure how do they deal with that
inside yes it was really interesting
because the the biggest knock on X is
that they haven't shipped a hugely
successful commercial product yet it
might be way mo which is seems to be
doing quite well but them self driving
cars exactly but Google Google glass was
clearly a huge failure and the lesson
they took from that is that they sold
glass as if it was a product when it was
really a prototype right and so what
they learned is that they were a great
scientific lab but they needed to be
more purposeful about turning their
scientific discoveries into products and
so I think that an enormous part of
working on hard projects is
understanding you're going to fail
constantly this process exactly it has
to be Derek Thompson thanks so much